while a great many people see you as
heroes there are some would prefer the
word vigilantes
we're here at day one and working out
right now is uh first fight between
Captain America and we want these fights
that be big character moments we don't
want there to be fighting just for the
hell of fighting there's a lot of story
coming into these fights and Sebastian
in the last one did a bit of fighting
quite a bit but not as much as he did on
this one said put in so much work in pre
prep to train these fights with Chris
the same Chris will pick up fights so
quickly where if it's hand-to-hand
combat
they're so good you can use them and
that is a better way to shoot fights
because you see more of the actor you
can shoot wider you don't have to hide
anything when it's your real actors
doing this combat
the Bucky apartment sequence that was
insane because that is like a
Kickstarter for action in this movie
because it starts with the apartment
goes to the stairwell goes outside the
apartment and then into the second unit
where they did that epic car chase
while a great many people see you as
heroes there are some would prefer the
word vigilantes
we found Bucky first we broke him free
so we in turn have the Winter Soldier on
our squad as well we also have the
Scarlet Witch I was just kind of looking
around like we've got a really good team
you guys it's not that way
and we had like all the jokey people on
our team are you guys - yeah don't worry
about right it's just look at the fire
service we recruit Paul Rudd recruit
ant-man Mackie does does Mac he has a
little history with him I thought I
didn't have any abilities what's ant-man
gonna do can't forget running I get
Hawkeye and sets that's a huge get we're
facing off what I think is a pretty good
team on the other side - if I think
about it